[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily day
two of the federal trial for three
former officers implicated in george
floyd's death and you're going to
present evidence as to his mental state
as
without getting into the issue with
competency absolutely will the accused
waffle house shooter argue an insanity
defense plus a sentence is handed down
for convicted husband murderer lynley
renick you're awful lucky ma'am
you're going to get out in your 40s and
my 40s weren't too bad
i just hope you don't kill again but
first i was escaping from being hit
as i got on the sidewalk i was fearful
fear of my life theodore edgecombe takes
the stand in his own defense in the road
rage trial out of wisconsin law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin both sides rest in the theodore
edgeco murder trial out of wisconsin on
tuesday the defendant took the stand
saying his reason for the shooting was
self-defense
he said
as he says
you can say what he said mr ed
damn you can't drive get the fuck out of
the road i accept responsibility you
know for punting mr clear me i was
infuriated for that shouldn't have
happened i seen them heading towards me
and i'm thinking if i get on the
sidewalk they'll at least tear up their
vehicle before they hit me
i just knew i just
i thought i was i knew i was going to be
killed upon him startling me and coming
around that corner i put my hand up and
i told him hey stop don't come closer
he told me i'm going to kill you now
this gentleman actually took
one large step and lunged toward me like
he was going to tackle me
and i took a step back
and as i stepped back it was uh
the reaction from that the firearm just
went off
and
with him lunging towards me i didn't
know if he was going after the firearm
if he was coming after me or what
edgecombe is charged with first degree
intentional homicide in the shooting
death of jason clearman a milwaukee
immigration attorney in september of
2020 when the two got into an
altercation on the road prosecutors say
edgecombe was on a bicycle when he
punched clearman through the passenger
side window clearman's wife was driving
at the time video shows as edgecombe
rode off the couple followed him onto a
bridge clearman gets out of the car and
approaches edgecomb that's when
edgecombe shot him he allegedly fled the
state and was arrested six months later
in kentucky edgecombe was claiming
self-defense prosecutors cross-examined
the defendant tuesday afternoon here's
some of the questioning on the next
episode of law and crime daily
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin to discuss the road rage trial
out of wisconsin bernard edgecombe took
the stand and in describing the shooting
it sounded like he didn't actually
intend to shoot clearman how does that
work with self-defense
exactly so there's a problem aside from
self-defense the reality is is that
during the opening statement of the
defense attorney he never bought it to
the attention of the jury that it was an
accidental shooting so the first time
that we're hearing that is accidental is
doing the testimony of mr etch call and
when you're talking about that if it's
accidental if it's accidental then it's
not intentional so in terms of
self-defense it's going to be difficult
for the jury to be able to apply the
standard because they have to look at
weight you're saying that you were
protecting yourself but if you were
protecting yourself it wasn't
intentional to take out your gun so how
was it that you were trying to protect
yourself so i think it's very confusing
for the jury and it's going to be a
problem for them it's confusing to me as
well bernardo but i'm just a public
defender i don't think edgecombe would
think i know much about that now terry
how did edgecombe hold up on
cross-examination were there any gotcha
moments by the prosecution
you know this was the most painstaking
cross-examination i've ever heard ever
it was so difficult granted the state
was giving compounded questions and
granted the state was sort of
mischaracterizing the facts but
edgecombe kept asking him one to
rephrase he claimed he didn't understand
and even when the state rephrased the
question
still edgecombe would not answer in a
yes or a no so he kept saying these
phrases that he was in fear of his life
that he was defending himself and
frankly i don't think it's going to come
across well in front of the jury the
only gotcha was when the state on
redirects said oh you know how to use
guns do you because you were trained so
yeah interesting cross yeah we'll see
how that comes up in summation i thought
it was a big point too as well terry
and in texas houston uh authorities are
on the hunt for an armed and dangerous
suspect they say shot and killed a
deputy on sunday morning officials say
this man 51 year old oscar rosales
is wanted in connection to the murder of
constable corporal charles galloway of
harris county precinct 5. there is a 60
thousand dollar reward for information
leading to rosalis's whereabouts
investors say rosalie shot and killed
corporal galloway just after midnight
sunday morning when the deputy was
making a traffic stop witnesses say
rosales got out of his vehicle at the
stop and fired an at an assault type
weapon at the deputy multiple times
after that he drove off at a press
conference on monday harris county
officials say rosales will be charged
with capital murder and asked the public
to help in the search
we have
word and other evidence that he does
change his appearance
so
there are individuals out there that
know him
but if
the public if you see him
he's armed and he's dangerous we ask
that you call
hpd
or the local authorities upon
apprehension we'll ask a judge in harris
county to hold him without bail
he is a bold and incredibly dangerous
fugitive
he is on the run and somebody out there
knows where he is as the former director
of crime stoppers
back in the early 2000s i can tell you
mr mr rosales you can run but you cannot
hide
anyone with more information should
contact houston crime stoppers you can
find the number on your screen
still ahead on law and crime daily
nearly four years after the deadly
waffle house shooting jury selection
begins in the trial of the suspected
shooter but first a sentence is handed
down for the missouri woman convicted of
killing her snake breeder husband hear
from the victim's brother after this
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
back months after the death of a
five-year-old boy nevada babies that are
charged with his murder waves the right
to a preliminary hearing 22 year old
lauren courtney is charged with
first-degree murder and eight counts of
child abuse in connection to the death
of five-year-old ryan peralto peralto
died in the hospital one day after he
suffered a fractured skull bleeding in
the brain damaged to his spleen liver
pancreas and intestines prosecutors say
courtney who was babysitting the boy
severely beat the boy after he urinated
himself courtney told officers she may
have been mad and quote blacked out
claiming to not remember the incident
she also claims she has mental health
issues the incident was caught on video
after the boy's father placed cameras
around the house because his
seven-year-old daughter reported
courtney was hurting her brother on
tuesday courtney waved the right to a
preliminary hearing she's due back in
court on january 28th
and a missouri woman convicted in her
husband's murder will spend more than a
decade behind bars after a judge
sentenced lindley renick to 16 years in
prison on monday afternoon
in december a jury found renick guilty
of second-degree murder and armed
criminal action for the death of her
husband benjamin renick a well-known
snake breeder renik testified during the
trial she asked her ex-boyfriend michael
humphrey to go with her to ask her
husband for a divorce she claims michael
shot ben micah was convicted of
first-degree murder in ben's death that
was later downgraded after he agreed to
testify against lindley lindley's
co-worker and friend ashley shaw also
testified against her saying she had
helped limly try to kill ben by
poisoning him and told the jury she
helped plan ben's murder at the
sentencing judge kevin crane said he
received several letters asking for him
to give a harsher sentence but he said
legally he could not exceed the jury's
recommendation of 13 years the victim's
brother sam read a statement on behalf
of his family he told the judge and
renick that her actions broke his family
apart
i'm here today to ask for the maximum
possible sentence of lenny renick
despite the verdict that we feel was far
inferior to what it should have been
i once again referred to the evidence
the premeditation
the cover-up of actions before
during and after my brother was executed
to this day i truly believe that lindley
renick was the one that pulled the
trigger unloading eight bullets into the
back of my brother benjamin reddick
she led me directly to my brother's body
and then put on a show
an act
a display that will forever haunt me for
the rest of my days
she cried over my brother's dead body
yelling why
how
pretending to me that she did not know
what she had done to this beautiful
young man what lindley renig has done to
her children
will forever be unforgivable
lenny rennick is a murderer
she will always be a murderer
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernardo velona and terry alson
to discuss rennick's sentencing terry
what was your reaction to the judge's
words of you'll get out in your 40s and
hopefully you don't kill again
you know it's a sad commentary when a
judge says hopefully you won't kill
again and it's saying something about
the criminal justice system in missouri
if you can't decide literally what that
sentence is going to be based on the
evidence and based on the facts then
it's difficult i think to say that the
system is just he can serve and do
things as far as whether it's
consecutive or concurrent the judge can
determine that but he can't decide to
give more time and so i do think it puts
the judge in a very difficult position
particularly when everybody is saying he
should have be able to give more time to
the defendant so it's a sad state on the
system of justice in missouri yeah now
bernardo the defense asked for 10 years
the judge gave 13 then another three
years to run consecutively not
concurrently how do you think he got to
these numbers
so the judge number one he definitely
exercised and and frustration over the
verdict he didn't agree with the verdict
he didn't agree with the sentence
recommended by the jury so since the
jury recommended 13 years of course like
terry said they couldn't go over 13
years however because there were two
counts that she was found guilty of it
is up to the judge to determine whether
it's going to be consecutive or
concurrent obviously the judge decided
to make it consecutive so that's how you
get to the 16 years the question would
be is whether the defense will appeal
this sentence as saying that it was
excessive but they won't be successful
in terms of getting that reverse or
saying that is excessive because that is
what the jury recommended yeah i agree
that might be a losing battle for them
there but they'll still probably make
the appeal and we'll cover it as it
applies and comes up thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily tuesday
marks day two of the federal trial for
former minnesota police officers king
lane and tao
plus the deadly waffle house shooting
will the suspect argue insanity our
legal experts explain the basis for that
argument after the break
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily
students returned for their first day
back at oxford high school in michigan
monday nearly two months after a deadly
school shooting four students were
killed and seven others injured after a
student ethan crumbly allegedly opened
fire in a hallway during a school day
the school's 1500 students returned to a
changed building as the school has been
renovated after being damaged in the
shooting students are also now required
to carry clear backpacks as a result of
the shooting the accused gunman ethan
crumbly is facing four counts of
first-degree murder and terrorism
charges his parents james and jennifer
are also facing charges related to the
shooting
in tennessee jury selection begins as a
so-called waffle house shooter stands
trial for murder
back in 2018 prosecutors say travis
reinking walked into an antico tennessee
waffle house he opened fire killing four
people and injuring others after a
34-hour manhunt rain king was taken into
custody the trial was put on hold for
months as reinking was treated for
schizophrenia a judge later deemed him
fit to stand trial at a hearing on
monday defense attorneys confirmed they
will address rain king's mental health
concerns during the trial but will not
discuss the issue of competency ranking
has pled not guilty to 17 counts
including four counts of murder for that
he faces life in prison opening
statements were set to begin next monday
january 31st however if a jury selected
before the end of the week we could see
openings as early as this week a judge
also noted the jury will be sequestered
for the entirety of the trial jury vadir
is expected to raise the issue of
insanity and its defense
criminal defense attorney bernardo
violona and co-host terry austin join us
again as jury selection and ranking
begins terry do you think the defense is
thinking about sentencing as they pick a
jury if so what are they looking for
they're thinking about sentencing
they're thinking about actually what the
verdict is going to be this is going to
be a very difficult case for the defense
i think brian because it's fairly
straightforward you're going to need
jurors who are very open-minded they
shouldn't
form any sort of conclusion at this
point and basically you will probably
see many jurors who've already jumped to
conclusions you want someone who
understands mental illness you want
someone who can be sympathetic maybe gun
owners and basically you want someone
who can apply the law absolutely now
bernard ranking's attorney will likely
argue an insanity defense how does that
work and what does it mean if the
defense wins with it
so in regards to ranking actually going
forward with an insanity defense one
thing that i will look for is to
determine whether prior to the shooting
whether there was any psychiatric
history was he ever put in a hospital in
order to bring that forward to the jury
so you can argue that it's not something
that is recent and that is made up
usually what happens if you're
successful it doesn't mean that you walk
out of jail what happens is that you're
committed to a hospital for a certain
period of time and it could be for the
rest of your life yeah we'll see how
that plays out as they set that argument
and jury selection continues when we
come back we head to minnesota for the
federal trial of the officers involved
in the death of george floyd who the
judge removed from the courtroom and
what bystander video jurors saw on
tuesday that's next on law and crime
daily
[Music]
welcome back to law on crime daily a
federal judge rules defendant michael
avenatti will represent himself for the
remainder of his trial this as the
disgraced attorney faces charges
stemming from defrauding former client
stormy daniels on tuesday a federal
judge accepted avenatti's request to
represent himself this means the
defendant will likely cross-examine the
prosecutor's star witness stormy daniels
avenatti rose to fame while representing
the adult film actress whose real name
is stephanie clifford she accused former
president donald trump are providing her
with hush money payments to quiet news
of their affair avenatti now faces
charges for stealing 300 000
out of an advance for danielle's memoir
about her affair with trump prosecutors
say avenatti forged her signature and
later lied to her about where the money
was going an indictment says he used the
money to pay law firm employees and for
personal expenses like making a luxury
car payment if convicted avenatti faces
22 years in prison in 2020 avenatti was
convicted of trying to extort millions
of dollars from nike he also faces a
retrial in california where other
clients claim he stole from them
also in federal court a u.s court
upholds the conviction of mexican drug
lord the so-called el chapo on tuesday
the u.s court of appeals in the second
circuit pushed back on no on notions
that a judge allowed jurors to hear
faulty evidence in a 2019 trial known as
el chapo 64 year old joaquin guzman was
sentenced to life in prison for 10
counts including continuing criminal
enterprise drug trafficking and firearm
charges the drug cartel leader was also
ordered to pay 12.6 billion dollars in
forfeiture in the appeal overruled on
tuesday guzman's defense argued he was
denied the right to a fair trial and
that he deserves a new trial based on
durham misconduct
moving on to federal court in minnesota
where testimony begins in the trial of
three former officers charged in the
death of george floyd prosecutors say it
was the duty of 36 year old two tao 38
year old thomas lane and 28 year old jay
alexander king to step in at the time of
floyd's death floyd's killing in may
2020 sparked national unrest after video
of officers surrounding floyd went viral
on tuesday a judge ruled courtney ross
former girlfriend of george floyd must
leave the courtroom after news that she
held a press conference earlier ross is
also a witness jurors were also shown by
standard video of the moments leading up
to floyd's death when officer two tao
kept bystanders at bay as chauvin knelt
on floyd's neck
prosecutors allegedly officers deprived
floyd of his constitutional rights by
not intervening or providing medical
assistance
of the three lane is the only defendant
not charged with failure to intervene
presumably because he asked chauvin
multiple times to change floyd's
position cameras are not allowed inside
the federal court where proceedings
began on monday the state trial for tao
lane and king is scheduled for june
bernardo in opening statements earl
great defense attorney for thomas laney
we may remember him as a defense
attorney also for kim potter said he
would testify how is announcing he will
testify helpful and do you think it will
win him the case
so in a case like this where everything
is on body camera and on video i
personally wouldn't have told the jury
that my client's going to testify
because you never know how the trial is
going to play out and maybe you want to
go through a different strategy by the
time that the prosecution the government
rests their case however i guess for the
jury they'll keep it in the back of
their minds we're going to hear from
officer lane so don't cast judgment at
this point we can wait so maybe that was
the purpose of the defense attorney
stating that to the jury yeah now terry
the video has been a focal part of this
case so far it convicted chauvin do you
think it will do the same for these
officers here
well i do think the video is going to
play a key role in this case but i think
it's going to differ depending on the
officer so we know for a fact that we're
going to hear from
tao that he wasn't touching floyd but i
think it video is going to hurt him
because all of the bystanders were
saying do something and in fact he did
nothing and we're probably going to hear
from king that he also was not doing as
much as chovin was doing and you know he
did take the pulse of george floyd so
we'll hear that in argument and lane
actually probably has the best defense
here he's going to say that he said more
than once that maybe they need to roll
him over on his side and in that way he
was trying to intervene and don't forget
lane also went in the ambulance he did
try to resuscitate and so he may have a
better argument than the rest yeah i
think it lands in a better spot but
we'll see how it plays out thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you